TV is a whole lot better than they used
to be over the past decade or so so
called prestige TV has offered audiences
superb acting cinematic style
unpredictable storylines and the epic
scope never before seen on the small
screen many of these shows are serious
sometimes devastating dramas with
important things to say both even
brilliant productions like these cranked
out plenty of ridiculous and hilarious
bloopers and outtakes Breaking Bad child
actors are unpredictable and the younger
they are the more unpredictable they can
be for productions only have a limited
time each day to use babies so they
can't wait around or when the baby feels
like acting especially since they don't
really know they're acting nor do they
care
take this Breaking Bad I'll take for
example in which the infant playing
Holly white makes some very interesting
choices for a character I don't think
she feels very safe Game of Thrones in
this blooper from HBO's fantasy epic
Game of Thrones
Kit Harington plays the corpse of Jon
Snow his body laid out on a table for
what will ultimately be his spooky
resurrection from the dead
snow was supposed to be naked in this
scene with only a modest genital
concealing garment preventing anyone
unset from seeing little Jon Deadwood
so many gag reels consist of actors for
getting their lines and swearing up a
storm but what happens on a show like
HBO's gritty Western Deadwood in which
half of the dialogue is already swearing
the actors simply burst into a song or
at least that's what happens when a
parent of Rolling Stones fan ian mcshane
can't remember what comes after a line
that includes two words start me don't
start me don't start me Oh start me up
and you start me up you're with me yep
sons of anarchy there's a lot of
Platonic male-on-male affection on sons
of anarchy especially in the form of
back-slapping bro hugs
but while shooting one of the show's
many action sequences actor Ryan Hurst
overestimates how far he needs to move
and the winds of unusually
place was followed gun-toting cover
seeking co-star Charlie Hunnam what do
you want for christmas Hannibal Brian
Fuller's artfully gory television
adaptation of Thomas Harris's Hannibal
Lecter novels featured many scenes of
its sensual cannibalistic serial killer
intricately preparing gourmet meals in
his beautiful kitchen a loss of that was
likely achieved through the magic of
editing because in this blooper I'm
Tomas Nicholson can't quite master the
show ah P knife skills I would be second
nature to the character vended have in
the 19th century Criminal Minds
despite the gruesome subject matter of
Criminal Minds it lives like the custom
crew keep things pretty light and loose
on set he's no longer with the show but
Thomas Gibson seemed to have a pretty
good time while he was starring on the
long-running CBS crime procedural like
the time it took him a comically long
time to put a pair of rubber gloves on
you know your prostate is about the
right size for a man your age
Lauren order SVU
when you're making a long-running crime
series about the most appalling of
crimes allowing yourself to laugh here
and there I'm set is a good way for axis
to cope of the depressing material case
in point
former Law and Order SVU star
christopher meloni can't get over how
funny it is and how utterly creepy he
sounds to ask a suspect for something
rather unusual would you mind if we took
a DNA swab from attention well even I
felt creepy
would you mind if we took a DNA swab
from you
help us even I I felt creepy again er
the hits MBC Hospital drama er made
George Clooney a superstar and not long
after he became one of the biggest movie
stars on the planet he also had a unique
way of coming up with some dialogue in
the event that he forgot a line while
filming the incredibly fast-paced show
which I don't want you to close your
eyes I want you to think of think of me
with no clothes on which is you shut up
yes orphan black Tatiana maslany plays
many different clones on orphan black
but they're all pretty different for
example Alison Hendrix is a high-strung
type-a kind of person
Sarah Manning is a self-sufficient and
streetwise rogue and the Ukrainian clone
Hellena always seems to have really bad
things happen to her in this scene
there's a scorpion are supposed to be
calling all over her Lena but Mars
Lonnie just can't keep it together
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel what
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]